>>> IN A WINTER OLYMPICS THA
SEEMED TO BE ROCKED BY SCANDAL,
RE IS A STORY THAT WILL WARM
YOUR HEART.
AMERICAN SKIER RYAN COCHRAN
SIEGEL WON THE OLYMPIC SILVER
MEDAL IN THE MEANT'S SUPER GIANT
SLALOM ALMOST A YEAR TO THE DAY
HE WAS IN SURGERY FOR A BROKEN
NECK.
BUT IF THAT WASN'T ENOUGH, HE
ALSO WON -- I'M GETTING CHILLS
WHILE I SAY THIS, THIS MEDAL
ALMOST EXACTLY 50 YEARS AFTER
HIS MOTHER, BARBARA ANN, WON
GOLD IN THE SLALOM IN THE 1972
SAPPORO GAMES AND THEY'RE WITH
US NOW, THIS MOTHER AND SON DUO.
IT IS SO GREAT TO SEE YOU GUYS.
RYAN, CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU.
TELL US WHAT IT FELT LIKE TO WIN
THIS, BUT ALSO TO KNOW THAT
YOU'RE FOLLOWING IN YOUR MOM'S
FOOTSTEPS.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, FIRST, THANKS FOR HAVING
US.
IT WAS A SPECIAL DAY.
REALLY FOR ANY WAS JUST A NRMAL
SKI RACE.
I WAS FOCUSING ON MY SKIING AND
WASN'T REALLY ABLE TO EXECUTE
WELL AND I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
COMINGING DOWN TO THE FINISH
LINE, I CAME DOWN IN SECOND AND
ENDED UP SECOND, AND WAS JUST
REALLY SPECIAL MOMENT.
I WAS ABLE TO CALL MY MOM, GET
HER ON THE PHONE RIGHT AWAY.
I THINK WE WERE BOTH REALLY AUTO
EMOTIONAL.
>> WE WERE VERY EMOTIONAL.
>> TELL ME MORE.
WHAT WAS THE CALL LIKE, BARBARA
ANN?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I MEAN,
PEOPLE ASKED ME WHAT DID YOU
SAY?
I SAID, I ACTUALLY DON'T EVEN
REMEMBER.
I THINK I SAID HOW PROUD I WAS
OF HIM AND HOW EXCITED.
I WAS JUST SO EXCITED.
I COULDN'T STOP CRYING.
I WAS STILL CRYING AND IT WAS
JUST -- IT WAS SO MUCH -- I
DIDN'T EXPECT I WOULD BE ABLE TO
CALL HIM AND FACETIME WITH HIM
RIGHT AFTER THE RACE.
SO THAT WAS IMPRESSIVE.
THAT WAS    SO EXCITING FOR ME
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
>> THAT'S A CLEAR DIFFERENCE OF
50 YEARS.
THE WAY YOU GET TO EXPERIENCE
THIS AMAZING MOMENT WITH YOUR
MOTHER, RIGHT?
YOU CAN DO IT RIGHT AWAY.
>> YEAH.
IT WAS DEFINITELY SPECIAL.
I THINK MY MOM -- HER DAD WAS
THERE AT THE OLYMPICS, WASN'T
HE?
>> NO, NO, HE WASN'T.
THEY WERE WATCHING ON TV.
>> I GUESS SHE HAD TO WAIT A
WHILE BEFORE SHE COULD TALK TO
THEM, BUT WE HAD -- WE HAD OUR
PRESS OFFICER MEGAN HARRIDGE HAD
HER PHONE, SHE WAS ABLE TO CALL
THEM UP IMMEDIATELY.
I WAS FULLY IN MY SUIT AND
EVERYTHING, BUT TRYING TO
CELEBRATE AND SHARE THIS MOMENT.
>> YEAH, I THINK I WAS STILL IN
MY PAJAMAS.
>> THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO WATCH
THE OLYMPICS, BARBARA ANN.
WHAT IS DIFFERENT, BARBARA ANN,
WHAT IS DIFFERENT IN THE FEELING
OF WINNING, YOU KNOW, YOU WON
GOLD, YOU MEDALED, WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE FEELING OF
BEING AN OLYMPIC MEDALIST VERSUS
WATCHING YOUR SON BE AN OLYMPIC
MEDALIST?
>> OH, I -- YOU KNOW, IT WAS
LIKE -- I MEAN, IT WAS EXCITING
FOR ME TO WIN GOLD BACK IN 50
YEARS AGO.
BUT IT WAS 50 YEARS AGO.
SO IT WAS JUST -- IT HAS BEEN
REALLY EXCITING FOR ME JUST TO
WATCH RYAN AND WATCH HIM RACE
AND SEE HOW HE'S DOING AND I
JUST -- YOU KNOW, I GET THE
BUTTERFLIES WHEN HE'S GOING.
I GET -- WELL, PLUS, I FEEL LIKE
I'M ON THE SIDE OF THE COURSE,
EVEN WHEN I'M NOT THERE, LIKE
I'M SCREAMING INTO MY LAPTOP,
GO, RYAN, GO, RYAN.
>> MAYBE YOU CAN IMAGINE -- YOU
CAN SORT OF IMAGINE WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO BE ON THE SLOPE, I
IMAGINE.
AND THE OTHER THING, RYAN, THAT
IS SO AMAZING IS YOUR WIN IS
SUCH A TRIUMPH CONSIDERING WHERE
YOU WERE A YEAR AGO.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT EVERYTHING
THAT YOU WENT THROUGH TO GET TO
THIS MOMENT?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, I THINK BEING
AN ATHLETE FOR THIS LONG, I'VE
BEEN THROUGH VARIOUS INJURIES
AND I KIND OF UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE IS
SO MUCH OUT OF YOUR CONTROL AND
IT IS JUST ABOUT WORKING HARD
THE DAY YOU HAVE AND GIVING THAT
YOUR BEST.
I WILL SAY A YEAR AGO I WAS
ACTUALLY PROBABLY STANDING RIGHT
HERE, STANDING OVER THERE,
HELPING WITH THE -- IT IS FUN TO
COME BACK FULL CIRCLE,
EVERYTHING I'VE BEEN THROUGH AND
BE HERE ONCE AGAIN.
>> RECOVERING FROM A BROKEN
NECK.
YOU MENTIONED, PEOPLE MAY NOT
REALIZE THIS, THIS IS YOUR
FAMILY SKI RESORT BEHIND YOU, AS
I UNDERSTAND, AND YOU'RE ALSO A
MAPLE SYRUP EXPERT.
THIS IS ALSO PART OF THE FAMILY
LEGACY.
TELL US ABOUT THIS.
>> I'M A MAPLE SYRUP TRAINEE, I
WOULD SAY.
MY OLDER COUSINS ARE THE ONES
THAT -- THEY RUN THE OPERATION.
BUT IT IS SOMETHING FUN THAT --
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF JUST LAND
WITH MAPLE TREES AND I THINK IN
2010 MY COUSINS GOT TOGETHER AND
CREATED THEIR OWN SUGARING
BUSINESS AND SO I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO CONTRIBUTE A LITTLE BIT WHEN
I'M HOME AND WHETHER IT IS IN
THE SUGAR HOUSE BOILING OR UP ON
THE HILL PULLING TAPS, IT IS
JUST FUN.
I THINK OUR WHOLE FAMILY LOVES
EACH OTHER AND WHETHER IT IS
SKIING OR SUGARING, WE ENJOY
THESE MOMENTS THAT WE GET TO
SHARE TOGETHER.
>> YOU MAY BE A TRAINEE, BUT,
LOOK, IN 50 YEARS MAYBE, YOU
KNOW, YOU CAN BE FULL FLEDGED,
RIGHT?
THIS IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO IN 50 YEARS.
BARBARA ANN, THIS IS REALLY --
IT IS AMAZING TO LEARN ABOUT
YOUR FAMILY.
YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF OLYMPIANS
IN YOUR FAMILY.
AND I WONDER, YOU KNOW, WHAT IS
IT LIKE TO HAVE THAT BE PART OF
THE FAMILY LEGACY, BUT ALSO, YOU
KNOW, IT SEEMS LIKE YOU ALSO
JUST MAINTAIN SUCH A CLOSE
FAMILIAL CONNECTION AS YOU'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF ALL THIS
COMPETITION.
>> WELL, IT'S -- COCHRANS IS SO
MUCH FUN HERE BECAUSE NOW IT IS
LIKE OUR KIDS' KIDS, OUR
GRANDCHILDREN ARE STARTING TO
SKI AS WELL.
AND WE GOT SOME OF THE
GRANDCHILDREN THAT ARE SKI
RACERS, AND I'M GOING, OKAY, I
KNOW ONE OF THEM THAT IS REALLY
INTO THE SKI RACING WAS ASKING
HIS MOM THE OTHER DAY, LIKE, HOW
MANY MORE OLYMPICS DO YOU THINK
RYAN'S GOING TO RACE BECAUSE HE
WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER
OR NOT HE WOULD BE ABLE TO RACE
AT THE SAME TIME RYAN WAS
RACING.
>> YEAH.
>> IT IS REALLY FUN.
>> HE CALCULATED IT THREE MORE.
THAT WOULD BE PUSHING IT, BUT
I'M DO MY BEST.
>> IS THAT MAYBE A LITTLE MUCH?
OKAY, RYAN, BEFORE I LET YOU GO,
PRESSURE IS ON TO DELIVER MAYBE
A THIRD GENERATION MEDAL HERE.
WHAT DO WE HAVE, PERHAPS, MAYBE
TO LOOK FORWARD TO IN THE COMING
DECADES?
>> NO PRESSURE.
>> I WOULD SAY NOT ANYTIME SOON.
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
PASS THIS ON.
IT IS A SPECIAL SPORT.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
SUCH A STRONG LOVE FOR SKIING,
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT IT IS
ALL ABOUT.
>> YEAH.
AND FOR EACH OTHER AND IT IS SO
WONDERFUL TO SEE RYAN AND
BARBARA ANN, CONGRATULATIONS,
RYAN, AND THANK YOU SO MUCH